[Music]
we continue our ongoing series it's
called a more perfect union this morning
to show what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us a
Georgian man is receiving a kidney
transplant today
what makes his surgery so extraordinary
is his very unique relationship with the
donor a chance meeting at a Cracker
Barrel in Georgia changed both of their
lives forever
mark Shelton is at the Mayo Clinic in
Jacksonville Florida with a story of a
stranger's kindness mark good morning
good morning at any given moment about a
hundred thousand Americans are waiting
for a kidney transplant five thousand
people will die waiting so this is the
story about two men perfect strangers
who proved that we all have more in
common than we could possibly imagine
we'll just get you the lie back there
pastor Edgar Roberts has waited six
years for this day a life-saving kidney
transplant
John Branson is the kidney donor and
Roberts answered prayer in April of 2016
the two men met him probably at this
Cracker Barrel in Valdosta Georgia I
walked in and I saw a guy Edgar
sitting at a table by himself and he had
a marine hat on and my son is just
getting ready to graduate the Naval
Academy so I walk up and started talking
to him Roberts a Vietnam combat vet is
now a 70 year old grandfather of two
Branson a 51 year old police lieutenant
in Anderson Indiana was passing through
Georgia on his way to a Florida vacation
so - you hit it off yes right away right
away could tell he wasn't feeling real
well that's why I asked him what was
wrong cuz he just looked drained and you
said just give off dialysis you wiped
out and yes why dad Roberts had lost
both his kidneys to cancer and was
receiving dialysis three days a week he
has been on the transplant weight lifter
that chance meeting the two men swapped
phone calls
Roberts health kept declining Branson
called again he's
already he's helping giving you hidden
what went through your mind I'll say
thank you Jesus
you don't get to me to me strangers at
you you know right where are good people
without exception and that's what I feel
that I care I got an extra kidney I
thought let's give it a shot and see if
I'm a match to Edgar
turns out Branson was a perfect match
this is a lifesaver yeah absolutely
absolutely dr. Christopher Croom of the
Mayo Clinic will perform the transplant
later today
ever heard of a donation quite like this
not like this I mean the the chance of
their meeting and them both going to a
place they weren't normally planning to
go in that morning I think seems like
it's just fate at Roberts Church this
past Sunday the faithful prayed for
their pastors transplant they also gave
thanks to special visitors Lieutenant
John Branson and his family he was on
the other side of the world I'm here in
South Georgia she come and give me a
kidney and he is a white guy and he
didn't have no reservation I'm struck by
the generosity of the offer
right I mean cousin strangers strange
faces what was the connection that made
that offer possible this is the ability
to do something really nice for someone
I mean I've been a policeman for 27
years and I my first offer is to help
he caught me on a real good day you know
and what's the connection like between
you guys now I was like divine intention
ease man but my brother that I inhaled
okay brother I had other mother Roberts
surgery has begun each the two surgeries
should take about two and a half hours
and if all goes well Nora the two men
and their families are planning to take
a cruise together this summer oh that's
nice mark what a wonderful story and
again a reminder that we are more alike
than we are different and that civility
should reign and so many people like to
have an opportunity to do something good
that they know what I have an effect on
another person's life on many levels you
have to like that story the chance
meeting the fact that they had military
backgrounds the black/white thing that
he pointed out it's just so one of those
things that makes you realize it's so
to live in this country and it's very
nice mark Strassmann very nice thank you